it's a lovely place they said its
regional Italian whatever that means
it's got some amazing reviews online you
know mostly it's worth about nine though
these are the traffic's heavy sometimes
you know it could be as late as 9:30
it's it's all right though because I do
have a book I grew up in the countryside
so I'm used to long distances
I've been wanting bikes until the kid
great knees laughs I'm not gonna traffic
you just have to make sure that they
know that you're there so it's a part of
data services where we hire the service
to take the pressure off them a few
times and then we charge them depending
on how much capacity they use
I think it's basically trying to make
like a point about women's position and
society and how capitalism basically
disenfranchises and alienates people who
don't conform to the heterodoxy you know
I think but like maybe it lends itself
to film noir too so I'm working for the
youngest partner it usually it takes two
years to reach associate status I reckon
I can do it in one hit all my targets
I hardly are the easy artichokes it's
such weird things really imagine the
card to the first person teammate one
must be truly desperate yeah nothing
next to the courage of the first person
way an oyster
and I'll certainly give it a few more
years and then who knows I mean there
might be opportunity for me in America
the company's based in Atlanta which is
in effect everywhere really
and they're mine and lost a leg no no no
no I'll get it fine sister she was my
idea
I'm Hughes they claimed I didn't expect
it
I mean it's so generous of you
this is great thanks yes so I guess I'll
see you around
it's just I'm trying try but you know
that lean in when it you're a bit more
confident you like I'm drinking wine and
I'm talking yeah okay